hey guys I'm Jackee Tris on the test
kitchen manager here at TC New York and
today we're gonna be making some Mexican
piggy gingerbread cookies also known as
Marigny toes the piloncillo
so here we have dark brown sugar but if
you're able to find Cologne CEO and you
want to use it this is it so feelin CEO
is basically hardened cane juice its
sugar in its purest form so something to
make your life so much easier is to use
a serrated knife you don't see you is
really really hard and a serrated knife
just helps cut easier my grandmother
used to make them for holidays or
special occasions when there wasn't
money to buy a cake or desserts these
cookies are relatively inexpensive in
Mexico because piloncillo is actually
cheaper than regular sugar so this
cookie is very very popular in Mexico so
modern interlinking it does just
basically translates to Piggy's so many
American recipes call these Mexican
gingerbread cookies well there is no
ginger in the dough but what I really
love about this cookie is that it's so
forgiving it's very hard to mess up and
it takes a few simple ingredients to
make something super delicious so there
aren't many Mexican bakeries here in New
York and that's why my mom asked my
grandma for this recipe so we would be
able to bring back a little piece of our
culture here into the city she used to
make them with whatever she had around
so that's why a lot of recipes call for
more spices we usually only had cinnamon
so that's what we use and she used to
have a little fruit stand so that's why
we added orange zest just to give it an
extra zing but honestly I feel you can
learn a lot from people through their
food because at the end of the day food
is what connects us all so if you don't
have a picky cookie cutter that's okay
don't worry you can use whatever cookie
cutter you have it will be less
traditional but you will still have
delicious cookies and that's what
adding an egg wash just gives your
cookies a beautiful shiny gloss in the
end it's also gonna help them Brown a
little better these cookies are just a
crowd-pleaser edges are super crunchy
and then you get to the middle and it's
just soft honestly it's the best of both
worlds
you can give them away to your friends
and family and they will love you
forever oh yes
[Music]
[Music]